[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm link and
I'm Rhett it's time for another
conversation with someone interesting
from the internet and this is a very
special episode a milestone if you will
because this is the 50 second episode of
ear biscuits and if you're familiar with
how time is kept and the fact that there
are 52 weeks in a year you know that
this commemorates one year o biscuits
here biscuits well but it's not the one
year anniversary that would be to the
next episode but it commemorates I'm
saying this yes this makes it one year
so if like you just took 52 and set them
aside that would be a year but then the
53rd would be an anniversary this is not
the anniversary this is the milestone
okay so at the round table of dim
lighting today we have grace Helbig the
sequel what we've already had her on the
show link that's right why are we doing
that okay we just thought it would be a
cool idea to bring grace back on she was
our very first guest and now one year
later is it - a week
you've really messed with my head and
just say the 52nd episode it's not one
year later because that was rude to
round out the year that we ringing back
now I'll star first guest on a milestone
episode grace helping so well part and
part of the reason is not just for what
we'll get into in a second which was her
perspective on what she got out of the
first time she was on the show but
because she's had a quite a year yeah I
mean there's there's lots to cover I
mean she cut ties with her main channel
Daily Grace and migrated all of her
content basically making the vehicle for
her brand a new channel it's grace which
technically had existed all along it's
kind of like a side channel but it you
know that was a big move she was in camp
Dakota she started a podcast she's
written a book so we talked about all
these things so it was kind of like
okay grace let's have a retrospective
with you and a little bit about her
perspective on coming back on the show
on her it's grace channel which is about
to break 2 million subs
she has a Friday show called fried diary
that's Friday and Diary put together
link just in case you didn't know and
this is when you know she blogged about
coming on the show again and we got a
clip to kind of give you a little
perspective on what she was thinking
this is called birthday vacation to see
two of my favorite content creators
Rhett link I refer to them so
professionally like content creators and
human beings in general we're gonna go
record a podcast with them I don't know
if you guys know this but I got to be
their very first guest on their very
first podcast last year and so we're
doing a follow-up episode of what's
happened this past year to be
interesting and also put a little on
guard because I think I got lucky being
the first guest on their podcast and
they weren't totally sure what it was
yet and I had since developed into this
really amazing podcast that ends up
getting like pretty deep and in
conversation with people and
unfortunately for me I didn't have to
get too deep with them now they know so
it's interesting that the show has
developed a little bit of a reputation
yeah did we succeed at taking grace to a
place of deep conversation you be the
judge I am glad that hey maybe this is a
forum for people to talk about things
that they otherwise wouldn't and to get
the to go a little deeper to get that
side of things I think that was the
design of the show when we first had
grace on we were just we were just
getting our sea legs yeah so to speak so
yeah I'm you know I didn't want her to
be nervous coming back on the show
here's a little preview what we talked
to her about we talked about her
personal and public life balance
including how she manages her dating
relationships in the public eye details
about her new TV pilot for E
and a potential next Miley here it is us
with grace
the sequel you know this is a nostalgic
episode yeah vodka for a couple of
reasons for us this is the 50 I think I
think this will be the 52nd episode you
are our first guest so maybe this will
be nostalgic for you because a lot has
happened over the past year literally
one year since we had our year biscuit
conversation we're having this one sure
so it's you know maybe we can go down
memory lane have a little you can
experience some nostalgia and saying oh
wow this has been a big year for you
maybe and we were thinking we could step
through some of those things first one
most recently is the new house so we've
covered that one yeah that's done but
since that yeah since that first since a
year ago you started your own podcast
yeah I started my own podcast that lives
on my own channel now which is also a
really exhilarating right we got that
too I remember last year being here with
you guys and I couldn't really even talk
about I knew what was gonna happen in my
future and really what I was about to do
and I couldn't talk about it to anyone
right so Daily Grace was a My Damn
Channel channel yeah it was a an idea
that was developed with My Damn Channel
back in 2008 and I was paid as an
independent contractor basically like a
hired actress if you will a hired
actress playing myself in a production
that they owned the the rights to and
they owned all the content so that was
it was a really bizarre five years yeah
five years yeah three the last three
were on YouTube yeah the first two were
only on My Damn Channel calm and then it
got moved over to YouTube and that was a
really weird experience of one learning
what YouTube was while participating in
the community and like meeting content
creators and finding out that my
situation was so different than everyone
else because I had no idea
and then being like oh how do I change
this this is not I kind of like it seems
extreme but I felt kind of like a fraud
every time I went to like VidCon or
playlist' that it felt like I'm no one
really knows that I'm owned by a
corporation that I feel like this like
human meat puppet that is promoting this
company because I mean that's that was
the feeling I moaned even though it was
a channel but the channel was so
inextricably tied to you as a person
Daily Grace that it you felt like you
were owned personally yeah I mean I it
felt a lot of like the milestones on
that channel weren't I didn't really
feel them because a lot of you know when
you you want to get viewers and you want
to get subscribers you want to get view
counts because that essentially means
more money for you and for me that was
never a thing I was getting paid a
salary so I could have a viral video
every single video that went up and
nothing in my life would really change
other than like you know building a
stronger better fan base which
ultimately was became like it in a way
it was great because I didn't have to
think about any of the financial stuff
with YouTube at all I could solely focus
on I want to cultivate a community of
really great people how do I do that and
I want to create content that I think is
really great so let's only focus on
those things because those are the only
thing you have control over right now
mmm
but then at the same time it was like
it's really frustrating when something
did really well and you don't
necessarily get the benefit of that and
also just not being able to talk about
it with anyone but as I slowly like
started talking more with people like
Hannah and and other content creators in
the space and the fine brothers I found
out the way that I was hoping I could
move forward with it but you I mean we
were talking and it was almost October
again a year ago you already knew but I
mean you ended up launching its grace
at in January wasn't it wasn't their
process to be like hey let's work this
out let's restructure this there was a
whole process of that and technically I
didn't know no until December that I was
walking away from a channel and you were
sure you were trying to restructure it
yeah there were negotiations happening
all the way up until December and the
leverage I had on the negotiations was
that I wasn't afraid to walk away from
it and to start a brand new channel and
just with the hope that the community
that's built is strong enough and loyal
enough that they'll understand and come
over because it's I hate talking a
business talk and especially trying to
explain business to an audience of two
million people as really none not
totally necessary either and so um yeah
I knew that my time trying to own
dailyGrace but they didn't own grace
Helbig
so you're just hoping like that your
personality and the intimacy that you've
built based on yourself is enough that
carries over so were they calling your
bluff I can't believe that they would
just they would allow it to get to the
they would force you to walk away I mean
that seems stupid it's yeah they didn't
think you would do it no I mean no I
think that they I to be honest I there
were a lot of negotiation negotiations
happening with outside of me with you
know my agent manager and with My Damn
Channel so I don't know exactly what the
conversations were I knew like the
things I was hoping to get out of the
conversations and that would be you know
relayed back to me and I hate
confrontation on any front so I didn't
want to be a part of those conversations
so they I to be honest I don't know what
they what they were wanting or what
their trajectory was or what else they
had going on that maybe was influencing
what they wanted to do I I don't know I
mean we we split really amicably we wish
each other well and and I'm not totally
sure what they're doing now but
hopefully it's something cool but you
said that you weren't afraid to walk
away and start your channel on new but
yet have been a little
Oh terrified yeah I mean I wha you're
afraid I'm not too afraid to not do it
yeah I was uh I wasn't afraid but I was
terrified yeah so yeah cuz you never
know I mean that's the thing with
YouTube in general is you could wake up
tomorrow morning and there's a whole
audience of people that are like we
don't think you're interesting anymore
unsubscribe and then think oh well it
wet okay well let's talk about the
dynamics of that because you know this
is in one sense it kind of defined your
year starting the the new the new
channel mm-hmm
you know did you I think something
there's some things that on the surface
that anybody can see right it's like
okay well you're not saying you've been
hazed you're saying you've been praised
you've been said you're not saying
you've user you're saying new person
alert and there's a and I think anybody
who thinks about it it's kind of like
okay she's doing the same things but
it's you're almost I mean even though
you've been hazed t-shirt is it's the
same t-shirt PR put over the age like
retinol and no it's so nice of paper how
much how much of that process of the
decisions that you made you made to keep
it the same but to keep a different were
based on almost a dig at having to do it
or just trying to keep it as close to
the original as possible it was honestly
trying to keep because I wasn't able to
the the thing that bummed me out the
most is that I I couldn't give like a
proper closure of that channel in video
form or even inform other people yeah
that this was happening and that I was
moving to a different place legally I
couldn't do that right but wonderfully
and speaks really highly to the
communities that people like John and
Hank green took it upon themselves
knowing I couldn't talk about it to talk
about it on my behalf and god bless them
they're far more articulate than I am at
speaking to an audience and so they
wrote some really amazing blog posts and
things got passed around so my thought
process was if I'm gonna start this new
channel I do want it to be my own I do
want to be new but I wanted to seem as
familiar as possible at least in the
beginning so that the audience doesn't
feel like that much has changed still
feels like
like the personality that you're used to
and the conversations that you're used
to in the topics and how everything
works is the same it's just a different
box clicked in your YouTube browser and
did you get yeah if you know we all know
this for making YouTube videos but a lot
of times people's uh not very high IQ is
revealed in the in the comments so I
would assume that a lot of people had
questions about why you were doing
things similar but different but had no
idea why it was happening yeah and the
really amazing thing about the audience
is that they're wonderfully
self-policing
a lot of questions were getting raised
of course you want to know why why why
why why and a lot of a lot of different
viewers were answering those questions
for me and in a way that was accurate if
there was if there were any inaccuracies
I tried to address them but I also
didn't want to I didn't want the start
of a new channel to be overshadowed by
the business side of things I wanted to
still focus on the comedy and the
silliness and whatever else
grace Helbig is as a brand and not the
legalese and all of that stuff and like
I said people like John and Hank were
covered for me and the conclusion of it
mm-hmm
was you picked up right where you left
off right isn't that what happened yeah
essentially yeah I yeah I just started
the new channel I started in terms of
performance though yeah there was
nothing new I I wasn't you know marking
a brand new style for myself or anything
like that and in terms of views you were
I mean subscriber numbers pretty much
migrated over pretty quickly right and
then really quickly it was there was
like over a million subscribers in the
first month which was crazy because I
you can always kind of try to project
what you think will happen but you'd
never know and because a lot of content
creators how many did you leave how many
subscribers in December I think it was
like 2.2 million I'm like that the most
jarring thing I think was that my time
channel I and I believe they're still
doing this continued
blowed my old daily grace videos that
only lived on yes I wanted to ask you
about that yeah I to be honest I had no
idea what they were gonna do with the
channel and I didn't really care to know
at that point I call it vintage grace
right yeah I'm not sure what they're
calling it but so for the first two
years that I did Daily Grace the videos
like you said I only lived on My Damn
Channel calm and so there's a whole
library of old videos that people on
YouTube probably haven't seen
so they started re uploading to YouTube
the videos from their archives every day
so it's like a weird younger version of
you in person
personating you write and the people
that weren't as competition and the
viewers that weren't aware of what was
happening we're like grapes did
something different with her hair today
so that one part was hilarious and so it
was a yeah there was this weird
confusing time where it's like oh
there's two new videos of me on YouTube
every day but I'm not posting one of
them and how long did that last it might
still be going on I don't know I haven't
looked I've tried to like you know the
same with like bad comments or negative
comments because they're said well there
was something else going on there for at
least an initial month when we were
looking at it there it was like a story
time you started that's how I started
making Internet videos is that I took
improv classes at other people's Improv
Theater and then there was an audition
for this web series and I did that for
My Damn Channel first and then we talked
about Daily Grace but you want to focus
I mean you you obviously not focus you
know what they're doing you're focusing
on what what you did and at that point
you were launching a new channel you
wanted to keep continuity but maybe it
was an opportunity to do things a little
bit different yeah I I mean I I think I
feel like now this part because the the
new channel has gone through a lot of
like for me creatively a lot of peaks
and valleys and especially because my
schedule this year has gotten really
intense and so I've recently downsized
to three videos a week because mentally
and physically I wasn't creating the
quality of content I wanted to
create by doing five videos a week
anymore and you know launching things
like the podcast I feel now this like
fresh air of inspiration because I feel
like trying to do the same thing that I
was doing on Daily Grace my brain just
started to get really stale and the
channel it's getting really stale and I
was traveling and couldn't upload on the
regular time schedule that I wanted to
and felt like it was stressing me out
and I feel like the audience could tell
it was stressing me out and so it wasn't
fun to watch some success stretched you
too thin yeah the projects that I had
started taking on and working with and
also my brain creativity had a lull for
a second and time I just wasn't inspired
by things I think I was doing a lot more
creative stuff that was kind of you know
using those juices in different areas so
I felt really dry when I came to make
sit down at the end of the day make a
youtube video and then I also felt like
I was just kind of recycling the same
content repackaged over and over so
right now I'm actually feeling a big
inspiration of wanting to evolve a
little bit and change not necessarily
change the style but just refresh a
couple of things and like really look at
it and make choices which I didn't
really do when I started its grace I was
like I was dedicated to keeping it
consistent so that the audience would
not feel the change as much and with
that I feel like I didn't give myself an
opportunity to make it how I wanted to
make it since I have creative control
over this now and now I do feel like I'm
getting there so within the context of
three videos a week mm-hmm you're still
looking at ways to change yeah I I just
launched the podcast which has been a
really cool thing to do and thanks for
having us you guys were great I love
that you guys were so you're really
great but because we don't really tell
you anything about what you're getting
into I feel like you guys were really on
guard for a lot of it and just like
waiting for something a lot of cotton
balls flying around here in the wings I
don't know what someone slap but so the
podcast is now had taken over the Monday
slot so I feel like I'm getting like
schedule a like I feel like a television
network or it's like I got this new
pilot that's taken over Monday nights
know was then was the title uh-huh
was that a direct reaction uh-huh
to you guys like our show oh you are the
inspiration for that podcast and I just
you know inspiration for the opposite of
it yeah absolutely I said that in I just
said it in my vlog on the way here I was
like I'm going to film this podcast and
I'm really nervous because I got off
really easily the first times they
didn't know what they're doing
I've heard nothing but like stories of
people being like just have written
things podcast I like I target like I
had I came back and she was like I think
I had to email them and say they can't
use some of the stuff I talk about I did
not have that experience it's about a
reputation at this point yeah I think
it's something everyone wants to do
because they feel like it's going to be
a therapy session they can't wait to get
all this stuff out there just and yeah
so I wanted to create the opposite of
that and that's why I feel like you guys
are on guard the whole time because
you're like waving for like this moment
of sincerity or a moment of like having
actual conversation I was like nope
isn't that good honestly I think what
you were sensing was I don't that's not
what was going on in my mind I think it
was oh I see what's happening here I got
to try to be yeah so that was really
what was going on was okay the setup
here is like I I have there is no every
question is out of outer space yeah so
cuz we try really hard to be funny right
we really put a lot of effort into being
funny every question was like I am just
really trying get to get some answer
together yeah like I could gush about
myself in my pain for hours but you
start talking about like the you know
the why my door won't lock
and who's taking a crap back there I'm
like hi
it's go time like the eyes are squinting
so it was yeah it was more put that was
a performance
I'm glad the comments mode I'm yeah
while I apologize for forcing you to be
on or feel like no it was good it was a
great opportunity it's just you saw it
you saw the gears turning it oh yeah
well now I think because well the other
part is that you guys hadn't gotten to
see how anything happened on the show
right on and now that like episodes are
out and then when we start shooting with
other people at least they can
understand like oh this is what it's
going to be right but I think you're
you're you're a gifted comedian and
gifted improv and I would say you know
if then if your note for us is hey
people are people might be intimidated
opening up I think our note back to you
is people might intimidate it might be
intimidated or sitting across in a seat
across from you and you're gonna kill it
and it's like okay what how am I gonna
be funny how am I gonna hold my own here
against grace yeah a potential guest
might be dependent on their chemical
makeup might be more intimidated by
glass than ours for sure
the and my director Jack fairy-like
loves leaving people in the dark and
that makes me so anxious as a person
that wants to know what I'm getting
myself into
yeah he and it's really interesting
because you can see right away who's
comfortable with not knowing and who is
it like for instance Mitchell Davis
whose episode is going up next week he
wouldn't just like a pile of
uncomfortableness because he was
fabulous
rising we sat and watched the whole
thing yeah he's a friend so he knows I'm
not gonna like do anything that terrible
to it why I don't know if he were if you
reveal this in the in the intro that you
do for him but he also didn't hear
himself for the first half of the
podcast I know his headphones headphones
were props I know
I'm like on top of you already been
anxious about not knowing anything so
he's talking very loudly during the
first half it's because he cannot hear
himself it off I mean I just I would
have been honored if you would have
caught it the anti year biscuit if you
instead of not been a little too direct
I am still honored that knows muffins
informed yeah
formation of your podcast and that you
actually had us on it so super cool
honored okay um so new channel yes
beginning of the year check right you
made it through that you even convinced
people to take two less episodes a week
and that seems to be doing okay yes so
check you lost your podcast yeah check
and you were about to launch the the
movie camp Takota was about to be
released when we were talking last year
this uh yeah I in my brain it doesn't
feel like camp Takota came out this year
it feels like that's so far ago that
that happened yeah so strange having if
it feels like a far-flung memory maybe
that allows you to say okay so what's
the conclusion you know I think from an
industry standpoint a lot of people are
saying we're saying what what does this
mean you know we're looking towards I
mean we certainly heard lots of
conversations if now what people say is
the camp Takota model yeah yeah it is a
model now in less than twelve months it
is the model yeah it's very strange
because we're not the first people to
have done this like Michael Gallagher
did smiley before we did this and so may
didn't release it in the same way yeah I
mean the distribution I think is a
little different and it was yeah -
Michael Goldfine who was our you know an
EP with us and who was the one that
really championed this idea I give him
so much credit for taking a risk which
is he did Kevin Hart's film before that
which was also a risk and a huge success
and so he that's kind of his his thing
and he gets the internet he understands
how powerful audiences can be and how
loyal they can be and that fan base is
a really important thing and so II we
none of us like when switching to a new
channel new how the audience is going to
take it but I think the way we what I'm
really really happy about and hope to
like continue doing in the future is one
work with my friends which is really oh
it's such a you guys know it's a great
experience
and two is keep the audience with you as
the whole process unfolds dailyGrace
that turned into a daily vlog about
being on set every day making this film
and so the audience felt like they were
making it with us which I think made it
feel more intimate when it came out it
felt like oh the project that I've been
working on with my internet friends is
finally out to watch let's all watch it
so keeping them in on the whole process
instead of being like tada
here's this thing that you didn't know
we were doing for so long yeah it was it
was really really cool and we broke even
on our budget in like four days after
the film's release which means you
didn't spend enough money yeah which
means we could have put in all those
lasers I wanted to put in the end of it
yeah yeah for us I just spent like oh
one we're not embarrassed by the film
itself we think it's a great movie and
two financially for someone like Michael
Goldfine who put up a lot of the money
for this it wasn't a bad choice right
yeah and so does that mean you're gonna
do that again hopefully there's a couple
projects that are getting developed
right now that we're all really excited
about because the process was pretty
smooth the first time around so why not
do it again it's not broke we meaning
the whole team yeah hopefully I mean
we've all gotten really busy Anna Mae
Murray and I over the past year and so
we all want to work together on on this
next endeavor whatever ends up being
it's just now managing more schedules
but um but yeah I'm really hopeful that
something cool is gonna be coming down
the
line memory and I have been working on a
lot of ideas and so it's it's going
really well so far like writing yes yeah
like um yeah we have a couple this is
the thing I wish that I knew I knew if I
could talk about this I couldn't talk
about this well uh I can answer that
yeah you can let me know buddy here this
round table of dim lighting is stopping
it yeah let me text my lawyer no we have
we you said coming down the pipeline so
it's a surfing movie
it's a surfing movie yeah I think
Jurassic Park but with whales no we have
a couple ideas that I am really in love
with and if I was an epic that's called
SeaWorld by the way no we have a couple
ideas that I if I wasn't part of coming
up with them I would be like really
pisses someone else came up with them
because I think they're really good oh
that's a good you know you've got a good
idea you're like yeah exactly
so so I I'm hopeful okay so what you're
just saying Camp Takota two camps got
into the sequel no we've all been saying
no there's not going to be a camp Takota
- there will be another project but not
Camp Takota - I camp Takota - will just
be the subtitle yeah how much of how
much have you written now Memory wrote
camp did you get yeah we anticipating
the writing on that one too I'm sketchy
on who sure Sam mamrie had the initial
idea she went to a camp she was a camp
counselor you know so she had started
this script and had like 30 pages done
and when she met Michael Goldfine he you
know had a raging boner for the idea of
a camp movie because he also went to
camp and I've never gone to camp but I
understand that it's very nostalgic for
people so they together came up and they
flesh out a full outline and then we had
a writer come on and write the first
draft of the film based on their outline
that was pretty you know intensive and
then mamrie went back and
two rewrote that draft in more of like
our voice okay and gave it you know
jokes and so is this one different in
that you're co-writing it no this one is
basically the same process memory and I
have come up with a full outline of this
film that's really it's really extensive
it's a long outline and then hopefully
another writer comes in writes the first
thing and then memory will go through
and totally redo that because she's
great at punching things up
she's great at making punch I'm punching
things up well that's exciting
yeah I'm excited it's like I said it
just comes down to a lot of scheduling
stuff your book yes comes out October
21st mm-hmm
how long has that been in a word in the
works and how difficult was it to write
it's interesting because people were
telling me that I said that to you guys
on the podcast last year that I said I'm
hoping that one day I'll write a book
and I didn't have the idea for the book
I knew yeah I don't remember that part I
don't remember either but someone told
me on tumblr they're like look how far
she's come
it's like I don't know so I Hannah and
mamrie had both sold their books and
I've known for a while that I wanted to
write a book I just didn't have the idea
yet and I guess it was kind of like
divine inspiration but it was like I
mean if they've got books I have to have
a book yeah well felt like right timing
I was like yeah publishers are
interested in this idea of internet
personality the same way like blogs
became books you know like look at that
hipster and like my dad says and stuff
like that so it felt like good timing
and then I had the idea that I wanted to
write I kind of tongue-in-cheek
self-help guide for Millennials I wanted
to give it directly back to the audience
why right for someone else if you know
who your audience is so I created my my
pitch and then went to New York in the
beginning of this year and pitched the
book around to a bunch of publishers and
before for your pitch you basically it's
like a PowerPoint presentation with like
sample writing and
what the books gonna be and how you want
to look in the tone and then you go and
you sit in a room with a bunch of
publishers and you just you basically
are pitching the book and yourself and
the whole idea of like this is my
personality and this is how the book is
gonna sound and this is who the audience
is and here's my demo and all my numbers
blah blah and then they all the
publishers will it goes the book goes to
auction and they bid on the boat really
yeah and then you can choose whether you
want to go with like the highest bidder
or if you want to go with a different
publisher because you had a better
connection with them and so luckily for
me one of the highest bidders was this
publishing company Simon Schuster that I
really touched on books that I really
want to work with and Lauren Spiegel
who's my editor is this phenomenal
amazing human being that has been with
me the whole time
and I also who pitched them on the idea
that I felt like I could write this book
really quickly and I wanted to have it
out by the fall which is insane usually
you have like a year or plus to write
the book and then it comes out later so
I was under this impression that I could
do that and I did it I wrote it all in
I think May and June hey guys we just
wanted to take a few seconds to break in
here and tell you about audible because
they're helping to make your biscuits
happen audible is the home to over
150,000 audiobooks if you're not
familiar with audiobooks link and your
biscuit ears that's a book on audio that
is a book that someone has read and I
don't mean like in a robot voice like
series trying to read it I'm talking
about like a person read the book and
I'm aware of this my favorite time as as
a child my favorite thing was miss
Lanier's class because she would read
you read those books man I mean it's
like it stuck with me and as you know I
was in Miss Campbell's class and she
didn't do that miss Campbell was a loser
she was a nice woman but I don't read
but Miss Lee like audible is like the
Miss linear of the modern day of 2014 I
don't know if Miss Lanier actually
signed up and read any of these things
like Miss Lanier is in your digital
device and this is not a
streaming service it's not a rental
service you actually own the books that
you download in audio of urgency here's
what you need to do go to
audiblepodcast.com/tekzilla podcast.com
slash rhett and Link now let's get back
to the biscuit so were you right was it
that easy for you it was ten months yeah
it was insane amount of writing and
there was a lot of like mental
breakdowns and that sort of thing but it
was great because I went to college to
be a screenwriter and I loved writing
and I hadn't had a real reason to focus
on it so it felt like I was exercising a
muscle that I hadn't used for a while
describe mental breakdown um crying into
cold spaghetti in a tiny hotel room in
London when you're about to go to do a
nofilter show what was put on a happy
thought what was the moment well there
was just broke you there were a few
moments where it just there it was
overwhelming there was we were doing our
nofilter shows in the UK in London and
Dublin at the time and I was trying to
do five videos a week and I was trying
to finish up writing this book that's
200 plus pages and I was there were like
four other things that were happening so
it was it was just like an overwhelming
time have you ever cried to your
audience I've ever cried to the audience
like in a blog no no I haven't um I've
gotten like emotional I've gotten like
sweet and sincere but I don't think I've
ever cried so you've almost like cried
tears of joy but never tears of sadness
no yeah I never tears a sudden well
there's one vlog back in like the early
days of My Damn Channel that didn't live
on YouTube that people have found I
literally came out of the subway one day
in New York and got hit by a bike and
then I was fine I just I'm camera no not
on camera I got really shook it up and
then I came home and I had to
my video but all the power was out in my
apartment and I just turned on my laptop
and I'm like kind of crying in that
video cuz I'm like just overwhelmed I
was like this just happened and now all
the power is out and I know this sounds
stupid but I didn't know what else to
yes I think that's the most like sad
emotional I've gotten I'm not a huge fan
of putting emotions like that out there
on the internet because one I want
people to focus on the comedy and two I
do put a part of my life out in videos
on my channel but I want something
that's just for me offline so that I can
maintain a balance and sanity who knows
at some point in the future I might
break down and you know put it all on
film well is there is there more of you
more of the personal side of you in the
book there is that's the other thing too
is that my editor and I really wanted to
make a point to put in personal stories
that I've never told online before and
there's a huge section of the book that
deals with like anxiety and panic
attacks that I went through a period of
time with that's all in the book that's
probably the most personal I've gotten
with the audience in like a creative
form and it was really refreshing and I
don't think it overwhelms the book
you're not reading a memoir you're not
reading an autobiography but and it was
great to hear my editor tell me that she
related to the chapters and enjoyed the
stories and then the tips the thing is
there's there's actual advice in the
book it's supposed to be funny and you
know tongue-in-cheek
but at the same time I tried to really
reflect on my life and think about what
I've actually learned that has been
really helpful for me and give that to
someone else because I think that's
helpful and a nice thing to do as a
human being so it was actual
soul-searching it was in a way yeah it
was really sitting down and I have a
terrible memory for even my own life to
think about like stories and events that
have happened to me that of like I'm
very good at repressing feelings and
growth in any way so there's only like
there's only a handful of really
poignant moments in my life that stand
out
that I wrote about in the book that I
think we're really nice to share but
it's not not exploitative and it's not
it's not too much I don't think I think
it's it from me validates giving someone
advice I don't like when people give
advice that don't I haven't actually
experienced the advice that they're
giving so instead of felt like here's
why
I know these 10 things I'm about to tell
you about so for the anxiety and panic
attack you had you felt like you had to
get specific in the book yeah that was a
big part of my life in New York and
moving to Los Angeles and I've talked
about it very minimally online but it
like reached a head right before I moved
to Los Angeles and so there's a big
chunk of that that I wrote about in the
book that I hadn't really talked about
before and it just give us a taste of it
I mean where did well i where did you
find yourself New York is well the thing
about New York is that it's an amazingly
cool city but you are constantly around
people all the time every hour of the
day all day long so you can tend to get
really claustrophobic and so I just had
a period of time where it kind of all
started to hit me at once that I would
get really claustrophobic every time I
left my apartment or every time I got on
the subway and I started having panic
attacks and I didn't even know what
panic attacks were but I was terrified
of them because you couldn't control
them and I was very much a person that
was into control in my life and so it it
felt like this side of me that came out
of nowhere
that I couldn't control and now I'm in
this city and everything seems like wild
and crazy and around me all the time and
what was the physical manifestation of
this like you couldn't breathe yeah
there's a liner where you were in public
yeah I would have to jump off the subway
a lot of times because I would just
start to get really hot and sweaty and
shortness of breath and feel like I
might pass out on this train or throw up
I remember I was coming back from
Manhattan once and I was feeling so it
was on a really crowded train too and I
had to stay
and and the fluorescent lighting on a
train is never that you know helpful I
think so I I started it really hot and
dizzy and honestly thought that I was
going to throw up in this subway car and
then I got out but it ever stopped was
it was somewhere in Brooklyn and I just
went and I sat in a Dunkin Donuts and it
was like snowing and cold and remember I
got out of the subway and like grabbed
two things of snow and like put them on
my face because I felt so high I'm like
terrible - that crazy woman I just got
out of the subway yeah I know and then I
realized I was like how can I keep doing
this if I can't even like finish a
subway ride like I need this mode of
transportation
howdy Junior how did you get over it I
don't you I went to a doctor and I I
talked to I got into therapy and so
we're talking to a psychiatrist
and things are more under control now
it's not you know you don't just like
take medicine and then it goes away
completely
you still it's manageable now and I've
you just learned your triggers and it's
really about kind of reflecting on
yourself and finding out like there's
something deeper going on it's
manifesting itself in this like state of
panic that keeps coming up so let's look
at that and figure out what that is
now that Amazon description of your book
includes says the book includes
everything a young are new or regular or
old adult needs to know from how to live
online to landing a job to surviving a
breakup to decorating a first apartment
and much more surviving a breakup so you
were writing this in May and June was
this were you writing about a recent
breakup the break-up that I talk about
in the book was one of the more poignant
breakups in my I've had very few
relationships I'm like a serial
long-term relationship person and I had
a really wonderful relationship in the
tail end of college and we broke up
after I live in New York for about a
year and and we still talk now and he's
a absolutely fantastic person but it was
a and he we had a really amazing like
two two-and-a-half years together and it
was at the point where
I realized that I wanted to do comedy
and he was realizing you know if goals
and dreams like he wanted to chase and
so it felt like a really beautiful magic
transitional time and then when we broke
up it was really it was dramatic and
that whole story is in the book and it's
it was one of the most painful moments
of my life when it happened but it's one
of my absolute favorite memories now in
hindsight the breaking up part yeah
relationship
yeah the breaking up part essentially we
knew it got to a point we were fighting
so much and we finally knew that we were
breaking up so we decided to rent a room
for the weekend at the Chelsea Hotel in
New York and just spend the weekend
breaking up and getting drunk and
yelling at each other and then we also
bought a bunch of art supplies and we're
just like painting things and I'm not a
good painter and neither is he which is
what the Chelsea Hotel is famous for you
got the artist types living in yeah
exactly and it was just like breaking up
constantly yeah making art you still
have these paintings
no but there's a photo online of me just
like on the floor painting it's really
dark and you can't really tell what's
happening it looks like it looks like
some six year old just gave me their art
and I like I'm surrounded by it but it
was great in hindsight it was like a
really beautiful weekend it was really
was that your idea or was it was like a
mutual idea we were in Manhattan we were
walking and we got in a big fight and
we're we didn't have anything with us
and we decided that we're just gonna go
to this hotel right now for the weekend
and then we said goodbye on the corner
of 7th and 23rd and then I didn't talk
to him for like two years after that
yeah we bunk I was at that moment mm-hmm
it was really crazy every time I walked
by a 7th and 23rd I always had this like
weird feeling but you didn't keep any of
the art no that was for room service
what happened here was that were these
five year olds able to rent this room
was that your is that still your longest
relationship or was there one after that
no there's one after that that was
really long but I don't really talk
about that kind of stuff
yeah that but that was one
the more it was such a transitional time
in my life and the moment like being in
that relationship is when I realized I
wanted to do comedy and pursue comedy
and that was like a really huge moment
in my life and he was part of that and
so there's always that connection there
it's interesting that the book was an
occasion for you to open up I'm curious
why because there's certainly a there's
a pressure with anyone who makes any
type of YouTube video you know if if
you're a comedian or if you're a vlog or
if you're a musician it doesn't matter
what you are if you're a youtuber there
is a there's an intimacy there is a
pressure to be to connect and to be
transparent to let to pull back the
curtain yet you chose you very guarded
there but then yeah the book was your
opportunity whoa yeah and even though
even though I say there's lots of
personal stories in the book it's not
you know it's not a memoir it's not
every story in this book and there's a
lot of funny fun stories that I haven't
told and a lot of quick anecdotes but I
do think that there's a huge pressure
for people online to be very transparent
to show you their lives and I'm I'm
guilty of wanting people to do that like
i watch reality television i watch
vloggers on youtube i want to you get
fascinated by human beings and so but
I've also never been a person that
expresses myself that way and so I have
to remind myself that that's not what I
want to do I'll give a portion of my
life sure I have fried Ayari every week
where I vlog my week and what I'm doing
but I don't think I don't think you have
to tell or show everything because to me
after a while of being so emotional or
whatever it might be it becomes kind of
inauthentic I feel like there's a lot of
because there's so much pressure to like
talk about thoughts and feelings and
fears and that and it's great and I
think the people that do it are really
helping their audience
there's relatability there that everyone
wants just feel like they're humans and
feel like yeah but you're certainly not
on that end of the spectrum no and I
don't think I ever will be I think for
me it's always been kind of a temple of
my myself and my brand to not reveal
everything well I can definitely relate
to that I think that part of it has to
do with seeing yourself as an
entertainer first yeah we definitely see
ourselves as entertainers first and so
when you begin to share too many
personal things you're like am i doing
this to entertain you mm-hmm versus I
think there are people who came up from
a from a different place maybe a more
traditional are vlogging and I don't
necessarily see you in the same way that
I would see somebody who just came up
through vlogging who is like you're just
experiencing my life with me and that is
how you are entertained right yeah I
don't yeah I didn't mean to cut you off
go ahead know that I feel that same way
and I say this all the time that I
understand that on YouTube there's a
certain desire for an audience to want
to see every inch of your life and want
to find out who you're dating and find
out where you live and see all those
things and that will garner a lot of
views a lot of people watch that I mean
as a teenage girl myself at one point in
my life I wanted to live vicariously
through people that I thought had really
cool interesting fun lives and but my
mission if you want to call it on
YouTube is to be a comedic entertainer
and so that's first and foremost for me
100% of the time
and I have to really balance that for
myself because because it is so popular
and because it is so prevalent online
the show part of your life and to
document everything I have to catch
myself from going too far into that area
because I think it's what the audience
only wants to see and reminding myself
that I am my own audience like what I
want what I want this for myself do I
want to put this out there like once
it's out there you can't take it back so
I have to remind myself to like maintain
the
the theory started with you're a comedic
entertainer but you put a you know you
start doing the Friday or how you say
fried they're right it's friary yeah
give them a little yeah and they're
gonna want a lot right and they're gonna
you know they're gonna start speculating
about okay is you know is she dating
Chester is that happening
hashtag dress so my mom are you guys are
you guys a couple I don't talk about
that because that's not important for
people to know I mean he might be in my
videos sure but there's no need to
acknowledge that and I think the
audience that the real audience the core
of people that I really want watching
the videos completely understand that
and I don't feel a Hannah and I have had
these same discussions because she's
kind of the same way she keeps you know
her romantic life offline because it
keeps you saying I don't want to be in a
relationship that has too many
microscopes on it I don't think that
that's very healthy I mean you guys talk
about your wives and children but you're
not gonna like always put them on there
I assume we don't put our wives in intro
videos because they don't want to be
there and we don't argue with them about
that great our kids are too young we can
force them to do no and they're at a
point where it's it's whether they are
excited about it or not yeah but yeah I
mean it's we we each have to find that
line and it's difficult I mean and I
would imagine at certain points it does
get pretty complicated hey I'm going to
Ikea yeah to get some stuff whoever's
with me is gonna you know that that
means certain things about a
relationship sure people can assume any
you can assume people will want to do
that any but you have to decide if
you're gonna well I'm not gonna what
kind of footage you're gonna put out
there yeah no I think I will let the
audience assume anything that they want
to assume they they can do whatever they
want and that's how I've been like I've
been in a bunch of different
relationships since I started making
YouTube videos and I've never talked
about any of those relationships to the
point that my previous
in ship it was a long-term relationship
and no one knew about it I would go to
youtube events and when I would mention
him people had no idea and I would kind
of pat myself on the back for that
because that's not what I want out there
I don't want that kind of speculation
and that's kind of how I wanted to
continue I'll show certain things and I
do kind of look at all of my footage and
judge like what should go in here and
what shouldn't go in here especially
because friary is still a relatively new
concept for me of doing more daily vlogs
like that or day-in-the-life blogs or
whatever you want to call them so it is
finding that balance and checking
yourself and making sure that I don't
only live online I live in the real
world as well that's just for me and
yeah it's just kind of like a personal
choice that I've made I said I don't
confirm or deny any of that stuff it
seems like you've made a decision to
you're okay with the speculation you're
okay with people having a conversation
but you and that may not that may mean
that okay I'm not gonna worry about who
is or who is not in my content or who
you see at my house or whatever but you
are not going to confirm you're not into
a to confirm it or discuss it with your
audience yeah I don't think it's
necessary I don't want it to become the
sole focus and I can see how for a lot
of other youtubers it has done that or
it has taken away I think something from
what they are doing and so I I don't
want that for myself I I still go back
and forth every week on whether I
actually want to do Friday if I wanted
to cut that out completely but then you
have the pressure of oh I started
revealing stuff about my life and if I
stop now that's gonna be upsetting to an
audience but yeah there's it's
interesting because even from a comedic
standpoint I feel like the pressure
there's a there's a whole set of
questions associated with this pressure
of transparency and putting your
personal stuff out there when you're a
comedian but
cuz it's such a it's such a turning on
of of a switch to be funny that you know
I've met people who are just you know
they're they're constantly on but more
often than not a comedian can turn on
and turn off and if the there may be a
fear of if I give them more of the off
me it will undermine undermine the
comedic me yeah or if do they want to
just know the gossip about me or do they
want to be entertained by right I don't
want to follow me in me yeah like I said
it's about balance and finding I want
them to be focused on the community
inside of me but I do understand the
value in the intimacy of showing your
personal life so I want to do both of
those things but under the parameters
and the guidelines that I approve of for
myself and to be honest I think that's
why mamrie and Hannah and I have all
become such close friends because we all
live by that kind of byline it's like we
talk about personal things but there is
a line where we realize no that's just
for me that side of my life like I need
to be a real human being sometimes and I
think that's healthy I don't know what's
gonna happen with it does ring of health
and that boy that's disturbing isn't it
yeah I know I'm always so not concerned
I guess concerned are just interested in
what is going to happen in the future
with how much things are documented I
very much have to check myself about
overly documenting things and letting
myself experience something with my eyes
instead of my camera and so because kids
are born with cell phones in their hand
I am I'm interested to see what happens
if everyone just becomes their own
reality show all the time it's very
fascinating well let's shift to the
television show tell us about the pilot
the Eve islet is
it's really cool so I sold this pilot in
the beginning of this year to II and we
shopped around to a bunch of networks
and there did just like a great fit and
it didn't happen for a long time it kind
of got pushed to the backburner to the
point that I stopped talking about
excite was assuming like a lot of things
in the entertainment industry they don't
happen so because Chelsea Handler left I
guess earlier than they anticipated or
leaving they you know put the green
light on and like rush like we need a
pilot from you and they have a lot of
other late-night talk shows in
development as means to try and replace
the the Chelsea slot and maintain that
audience so who knows what's happening I
know that the pilot that I made for them
I'm really proud of and I'm not
embarrassed because going to like the
traditional machine the of media is a
little scary because you do lose some
creative control because you're
collaborating now with the traditional
Network and so I wanted if anything they
didn't have to pick up the show at all I
just don't know if they have I just
wanted to create something that I was
really proud of that if they did pick it
up I wouldn't be like well now I have to
do this show That's not me and I have to
pretend it is how did you how did you
communicate that I communicated it by
creating a late-night show that's kind
of like the introverts talk show it
happens in my house the same way my
videos happen and all the guests come to
me and we hang out there and it's really
low-key and not in front of a studio
audience but I so maintain my normal
life around it I'll go run errands I'll
interview people in my car while I'm
doing other things and getting you know
takeout and that sort of stuff so it
feels um it feels really low-key and
casual and silly and fun and the
conversations a lot like the podcasts
are kind of nonsensical but they also
draw from the internet where I wanted it
to be interactive in that way people
submitted stuff through Twitter that got
used in the show and so it's a I'm
really proud of it because I've been
fumbling in my brain with the idea
knowing that TV was a goal at some point
at least
and people like Chris Hardwick and Andy
Cohen do a great job of trying to merge
the Internet into a comedy show and so I
was trying to figure out how to do it
and it became like this convoluted like
overly complicated thing of like well
they have a live stream during the show
and well and all this stuff and and so
just kind of paring it down and having
the voice of the vlog that I have but
making it feel big enough that it should
exist on television and so you actually
made the pilot we made the pie we shot
the pilot in 322 million is an hour or
22 minutes a 22 minute pilot we shot in
three days we shot it in between two
separate shoots for hay USA the travel
show that member and I did so the great
thing about that is that I didn't have
time to overanalyze everything that was
happening it was just like put your head
down and go can you tell us who was on
it like guests I think I can Tom Lennon
was on it from Reno 911 I systemin being
and has a philosophy of work in life
that I totally subscribed you
I kept thanking him for taking the time
out his day to come and do this
interview and he his response was just
why wouldn't I
why wouldn't I I had time so yeah of
course why wouldn't it like he was just
really well like I said he was on our
show super nice like he gets like the
hustle he understands that like it's
you're never like too good for anything
or it was really it was really
refreshing and really nice and he was of
course hilarious
what's he be only guest didn't know EJ
Johnson was who was like an E
personality he's on rich kids of Beverly
Hills it's reality show okay and
memories on the show as well aims at
magics son yeah okay yeah and he's
fantastic
he is this like fabulously rich gay boy
that is so sweet and so nice and I was
really intimidated when he I found out
he was going to be our second guest
because he's fabulous and I'm picking
him up in a rented Priya wearing
like flannel and cutoff jeans I mean
like hello and then telling him that
I've never been into a Nordstrom before
and him like almost choking on his own
spit so you would like miked up the car
and it happened in the car yeah we did
it I I leave my interview with Tom to go
pick up mamrie and while I'm on the way
picking up mamrie I pick up EJ and
there's just a bunch of GoPros and I
just talk to him in the car and mamrie's
like in the backseat and the memory
comes in and we forced him to sit in the
backseat I mean this is my friend I
don't really know you so you've just in
the back and then we go to Del Taco and
we get just that was my favorite part
was watching EJ Johnson who's wearing
carrying a purse that costs more than my
house and where I like the scarf thing
just eating a Del Taco in the back of
the sky it was great so it's it's a
simple show and it's fun and it feels
what's it called right now it's called
grace Helbig has a television show yeah
really cryptic time when do you expect I
know you can never expect these things
but when you hope to hear or something
being feedback is really positive it's
out to focus groups right now okay I
know it's just so scary
it's your show and your entire future is
in the hands of like dials where it's
like I'm interested turn to the right
turn to the left when you're
uninterested in something which sounds
like kind of degrading but I understand
why they do it so we'll find out at the
end of the day like I said I'm really
happy with the piece of content that we
made and I'm slowly I don't really have
like a bucket list and I never have had
like here's my five-year plan but as
I've been doing things in my life I feel
like I'm creating and also crossing off
things on my bucket list as they happen
so for me I'm like if this doesn't get
picked up and I never do a pilot again
at least I did that and I made one that
I'm really happy with so great job and
what happens if it does get picked up
how does that impact the rest of the
grace help
world I'm not totally sure I think if it
gets picked up I have to evaluate it
I won't stop making youtube videos it's
just how do I make content that exists
online and how do I make content for a
television that are all within the same
brand and within within the same
umbrella but don't overlap so you
students would be a daily show Monday
through Friday I think you would start
as a weekly show and then depending on
how it goes who knows but I think it
could be really interesting and it if it
did get picked up it would be
reevaluated we're not rebelling just
evaluating how does this all work
together let's figure this out well you
know we've talked about you know I think
when you really sit back and think about
all we've talked about you've had an
incredible year right we're there with
all this stuff that's that started and
all the things that you've accomplished
when you think about those things you
think about the book you think about the
TV show you think about the podcast and
the movie how does that make you think
about the core of what it was you know
what it was in in being a youtube
channel and it's now it's so much bigger
how does it make you think about the
sustained success how important is this
a sustained success of that main YouTube
channel to you at this point it's hugely
important and hannah has this quote that
I use all the time now that I was on a
panel with her since you're about to use
it again yeah I am get ready
she says dance with the one you came
with which makes so much sense to me and
like really was a turning point and how
I thought about YouTube when I heard her
say that YouTube has afforded me a lot
of these opportunities and for me to not
focus on maintaining that my channel I
think would be a real bad thing so I the
it's interesting during this podcast cuz
I don't really give myself time to
reflect on a lot of things that have
happened especially in the past year
because I'm always have the mindset of
like just work forward forward momentum
no time to really like look back because
that'll slow you down and then voila so
so it's crazy and the only thing I can
hope to continue
is making things that I would want to
watch if I wasn't me or want to be a
part of this I wasn't me and to
cultivate hopefully an audience of
people that are nice cool fun
interesting people with a lot of
potential and so far that's been
happening so it's maintaining that how
that happens not totally sure well I
think it is happening has happened this
year and I think it's gonna keep
happening yeah and we can't wait to see
what that is so and then a year from now
hopefully you'll be back here talking
about it yeah I finally have my line of
airplanes that I wanted to release I
will still be living or at least one of
us oh yeah and I volunteer to be the one
okay why didn't it work that's the deal
you come back in a year and at least one
of us will still be okay
here it's a promise unless we die in the
same accident that could happen I don't
want that my turn yeah we made it about
us yeah we talked about that thanks so
much grace you signed the table again
yeah how does that work you know what
yes you did scientific sound I was just
looking at how you can get a lot from
someone based on their signature and my
signature is so obnoxious there's
exclamation points after it I would hate
me if I didn't know yeah I'll just trace
my own signature well it says grace one
so you should put a grace to some bone
there you go it's as if I knew that I'd
be back
[Music]
there it is an ear biscuit second
biscuit with grace Helbig I'm really
glad that grace came back on you know
we're friends huge fans of hers
and you know I guess I was a little
flattered to see in her vlog that she
was nervous to be on the show she I
guess she told us that too we started oh
wait what are you guys gonna get out of
me this time now that you've you know
figured out how you what's your approach
and I do think that we haven't really
talked about this I think the two guys
sitting across the table from you one
who's very large and one who is actually
larger than average but people don't
realize it because the other guy is so
large I think that might be intimidating
or at least unfair it's kind of like a
the words not a trial but what's the
word I'm looking for an inquisition
inquisition it's not an inquisition you
don't have to convert um I do think that
we kind of got to know more of get in
Grace's headspace and kind of understand
you know her approach in separating her
personal life from her her comedic
public life because she was able to be
very open about her philosophy of
neither confirming nor denying certain
details of her personal life without
being open about those specific details
that that's there's a nuance there but I
think it's important because she wasn't
just like I don't talk about that shut
up yeah she was I don't talk about that
now let me talk about why I don't talk
about that and I got to say I respect
that I appreciate that like you
acknowledged when we talked to her there
are some things that we don't get into
we don't talk a whole lot about our
relationship with our wives with our
wives are not in our videos as an
example of one places that we've kind of
drawn a line sure I mean she's a
comedian yeah she's not a reality star
right and there's a there's a
professional choice to be made there as
well as a personal choice you know I
want people to want to spend time with
me online because
I'm entertaining and I'm funny not
because I'm there's something some juicy
detail in my personal life that in it
happens to entertain you and I will say
that there are a lot of people I would
say I would almost characterize it as a
YouTube generation that is characterized
by you are entertained by the fact that
they are so open about their lives I'm
not judging that and I'm not saying it's
right or it's wrong I'm just saying that
I personally I don't know you do too and
grace much more relate to I want to
entertain you and I want to give you
enough of myself personally so you can
connect but you're not being entertained
by the connection exclusively you're
being entertained because well I'm
thinking about what I'm saying and I'm
trying to make it funny and I'm trying
to make it interesting you know and I
think that that's that that's a
distinction and I think that you can
only respect that let grace know what
you think of her willingness to go
deeper here on your biscuits tweet at
her grace Helbig that's her name and her
Twitter handle
yeah it's pretty good and you know what
look out for the book October 21st
right around the corner October 21st is
when the book will be available I think
it's available for pre-order now is that
when it becomes available for pre-order
pre-order now appear now but you can
actually buy it then Grace's guide book
dot-com so check that out Grace's guide
the art of pretending to be a grown-up
and as always we appreciate your
feedback your ratings and reviews on
iTunes your comments on soundcloud
thanks for letting us insert this
biscuit into your ear we will do it
again next week
hashtag ear biscuits will speak at you
[Music]
[Music]